hi hello
we'll start with two three two and then
move on to three one six
hi Sarah Mary medaya from CBC Radio
Canada nice to see you hi nice to see
you obviously you're making a lot of
women proud tonight and a lot of
Canadian women proud tonight just tell
me what does it represent to win this
award and be recognized for the work
that you've done on women talking thank
you so much um I I'm just thrilled that
this is a recognition that our whole
film is getting it was an incredible
collective experience and even adapting
this screenplay itself was the result of
so many conversations with so many
people who weren't named as nominees
tonight and so this feels like it's for
this amazing Collective group of people
who really brought a lot of their own
lived experience to this film I'm very
excited about it and honored by it thank
you
okay three one six and Then followed by
a question from the virtual Press Room
uh Sarah congratulations it's Mark
Williams from British cinematographer
and below the line here on your left a
little bit in the back
hand waving here you know how you do so
again I would love for you to expand on
those contributions I know this is for a
writing award but for the totality of
the film with the great contributions
that you got in production design and
cinematography and all these craft
elements could you expand on how those
helped come helped your written work
come alive I really appreciate the
question so there are a lot of crew
people that I show my scripts to at the
very very beginning the very first draft
of it they include my casting director
John buckin and Jason Knight
um Luke Montpellier my cinematographer
who I've worked with since my very first
short films and a lot of people my my
post sound supervisor David McCallum I
have a lot of people weighing in very
very early in the process and and this
screenplay especially
um with Dede Gardner and Frances
McDormand was the result of a lot of
conversations with us and then that
extended into the editing room and was
changed a lot in the editing room so my
editors Christopher Donaldson and Roz
kalu you know the the screenplay was an
Ever evolving thing a lot of actors came
up with ideas a lot of crew members in
the moment would bring their own lived
experience into the room and we would
change the script based on it so it was
this very alive active document that was
constantly being collectively built and
I'm I'm sure I'm forgetting a lot of the
names of the people who contributed
right now but it was not one person so
thank you
and our final question will go to the
virtual Press Room um cinephilis can you
please ask her a question
yes hi Sarah my name is Fran from
Cinepolis Latin America congratulations
and I really wanted to know
um even in the worst conditions you
recreate that the power of dialogue and
collectiveness is really important
and how you create that in safe
environment I really wanted to know how
cathartic was for you and for all the
participants in the movie
try to get them more authentic
performance there
I mean it was a beautiful experience
because of the people that were in the
room with us and I think we live in a
world right now where we're kind of
creating stories and then shaking our
narratives at each other and cheering
for a side and it's you know
conversation has become like a sport as
opposed to genuine exchange and
listening and the act of changing one's
mind or being open to either changing
one's own mind or somebody else's and so
for us all to be in an environment where
you know that was the organizing
principle in a way of what happens in
the story that really um was contagious
and it really impacted the way we all
worked and that was a beautiful very
transformative thing for a lot of us
wonderful thank you so much and
congratulations thank you so much thank
you